the association between the great Irish
writer Samuel Beckett and the game of
cricket deserves to be more widely known
he was a fine player when a student at
Trinity College Dublin and even merits a
mention in a famous wisdoms the
cricketers Bible the only Nobel Prize
winner to be so lauded on one occasion
in the mid-1960s
Beckett travelled from Paris to London
to watch the Test match between England
and Australia it was a beautiful sunny
summer afternoon
blue skies Lord's Cricket Ground green
and glorious one of his friends remarked
what a wonderful day this is a sort of
day that would make you glad to be alive
- which Beckett responded dryly I
wouldn't go as far as that the story
nicely encompasses two aspects of Samuel
Beckett his famously bleak view of life
and his mordant sense of humor if as
horace walpole remarked the world is a
comedy to those who think and a tragedy
to those who feel it is fitting that
Beckett's Waiting for Godot is subtitled
a tragic comedy in his theatrical images
and prose writings Beckett achieved a
spare beauty an articulation of human
suffering shot through with dark comedy
and humor it seems almost too
coincidental that this most famous
dramatist of desolation whose work teams
with biblical allusion would be born on
the day of the crucifixion yet Samuel
Barclay Beckett was born on Good Friday
13th of April 1906 in the affluent
village of Fox Rock eight miles south of
Dublin Beckett was educated at portora
royal school and his killen now in
Northern Ireland the alma mater of
another great Irish playwright Oscar
Wilde where he excelled academically and
at sports he graduated from Trinity
College Dublin in 1927 first in his
class and was awarded the college's gold
medal he seemed destined for a
glittering academic career and in
October 1928 he headed to Paris for a
two-year exchange fellowship at the
distinguished economist Subbarao his
immersion in the Parisian literary scene
had a profound impact on the young
Irishman he became attached to the
of another great Irish writer James
Joyce the revered author of Ulysses
published in 1922 and in 1929 published
his first critical essay on Joyce's work
in progress which would become fatigue
ins wake on his return to Dublin Beckett
was unhappy lecturing at Trinity College
and resigned after little more than a
year he often said that he gave up his
job because he could not bear teaching
to others what he did not know himself
at this point Samuel Beckett determined
to be a writer and a man of letters in
1931 he published a short critical book
Proust on the great French writer which
brilliantly identified that Proust was a
philosopher and his long novel was in
essence a search for the meaning of life
which rests Proust thought and Beckett
agreed on the making and appreciation of
art despite the brilliance of this essay
Beckett would have many setbacks and
rejections in his attempts to establish
himself in the literary world an echo of
the themes of failure that would so
dominate his work he failed to get his
first serious attempt at a novel dream
affair to middling women published
though much of it was reworked into a
short story collection more pricks than
kicks which came out in 1934 the next
year he published a slim volume of
poetry echoes bones and other
precipitates marked like much work of
this period with dense erudition
and pessimism Beckett's London novel
Murphy was completed in 1936 this comic
novel of ideas is probably his most
accessible least experimental
full-length work though this didn't stop
it going through 42 rejections before
finally being published by ravage in
1938 Beckett had long suffered from
panic attacks anxiety and depression
often with terrible physical
manifestations he went to London in the
early 1930s to undertake psychoanalysis
with a famous British analyst Wilfred
Bion the interest he developed in
psychology and psychiatry showed
constantly in the asylum scenes in
Murphy and in his next novel what
written while hiding out in rural France
during the Second World War his personal
experience of psychotherapy emerges too
in his later work much of which is in
the form of a monologue whereas speaker
Gables in a kind of delirium
to a faceless listener much as one might
at moments in analysis though Beckett's
works are highly nonspecific and tend
not to refer explicitly to the Second
World War or other historical events
there is little doubt that the traumas
of history deeply scoured his
imagination appalled by the treatment of
his Jewish friends under Nazi occupation
Beckett became actively involved in the
resistance in Paris principally as an
information handler Beckett's experience
of the war and the devastation he
witnessed in France afterwards seems to
have contributed to a radical change of
direction during a return visit to
Dublin in 1946 Beckett had a vision or
revelation of literary purpose which
marks the divide between his 1930s work
third-person erudite and Missy and and
the dwindled bewildered first-person
story telling of his mature prose unlike
some of his early writing which shows
the influence of Joyce in his wordplay
and heavy allusion to other literary
works the post-war work carries its
learning more lightly making ignorance
impotence and failure its key
preoccupations this change in direction
was accompanied by the decision to write
in French there followed between 1946
and 1950 a frenzy of writing which
included much of the work of which
Samuel Beckett is now famous namely
Waiting for Godot and his great trilogy
of novels Malloy Malone dies and the
unnameable oniton dog order was written
between October 1948 and January 1949 as
a diversion from the more taxing as
Beckett's Soret business of prose
composition it was eventually staged in
a small avant-garde Parisian Theatre in
January of 1953 the plays immense
success generated international
controversy and wide interest set on a
bare stage apart from a lone tree and
one rock with two characters exchanging
inconsequential dialogue while waiting
at the side of a road for a character
who never comes Beckett's play provoked
confusion and hostility when an English
version transferred to London in 1955 it
was greeted with whistles and jeers of
derision
however Waiting for Godot
sukh CETIS condyle and is arguably the
most influential play of the whole of
the 20th century gato presents a dark
vision of human life mixed with plenty
of vaudeville antics and slapstick
comedy the play's action or inaction
seems at points suggestive of universal
or an existential condition but at this
place and at this moment in time all
mankind is us whether we like it or not
declares one character did the non
arrival of God Oh
critics pondered suggests the absence of
God in the modern world or did the play
rather dramatize the yearning and sense
of incompleteness in which we live most
of our lives most people after all
exists in a state of anticipation or
future-oriented Ness once I get the
right job or the right house or my
beloved said yes or I retire then I will
be happy
but once desire or ambition is realized
we start to want something else
the ultimate satisfaction the god oh who
will give us final fulfillment never
arrives
yet for all these philosophical
interpretations nothing is certain in
Beckett's work he once remarked that the
key word in my plays is perhaps it may
be that Beckett's greatest achievement
is as brave depictions not of a
pessimistic outlook but of a bewildered
one if we leave his plays perplexed then
this is an appropriate response we too
are waiting for something that never
arrives the reassurance of a clarity of
meaning of certainty even the certainty
of darkness Beckett was almost
instinctively a master of the stage his
next great play endgame in 1957 gives us
the enduring image of human beings in
dust bins outside the room in which the
action takes place all seems dead gray
and corpse in some sort of post
apocalyptic devastation that speaks
urgently to our own era of environmental
crisis though a black humour in Jaws
even human values and meanings
seem to be draining away one character
remarks as if an answer to those who
would turn Beckett's work into mere
philosophy means something you and I
mean something huh that's a good one as
his career progressed Beckett's plays
and prose
generally became ever more condensed and
minimal the plays would often focus on a
single intense image a woman buried up
to her waist in the sand happy days a
man and two women fixed in some sort of
purgatorial urns babbling out the story
of their adulterous triangle play a
single illuminated mouth telling stories
in the third person
terrified of using the word I not I
Beckett gives us works of art that offer
an experience not just an idea or a
takeaway message he takes us into the
perplexity of the modern condition in
which the traditional consolations
belief in a providential plan or hopes
for civilizational progress have been
shattered by the barbarism of war and
Holocaust
yet if Beckett's work presents us with
human extremity there are moments of
fellow feeling of compassion and of
exquisite black humour moreover his
writing is marked with the most
scrupulous exactitude and precision
there is a shape to his chaos one which
emerges with a sort of wintry serenity a
combo etic structure to his plays it is
this formal and artistic achievement
that allows us to cherish in Beckett's
work a fragile necessary grace we love
bringing you these films if you want to
help us to keep bringing you thoughtful
content please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen now
you